i thought the person who could help uh
do that and call in law enforcement is
joins us now
you saw those runners fleeing on live
national television here on fox news
just a stark and brazen example
of how out of control the southern
border seems to be
that man live is texas attorney general
ken paxton uh just outside dallas mr
paxton mr a.g i mean you seeing these
guys run does it make you feel like you
want to pull out your cell phone get on
the phone and say go down to la jolla
with
we got some i mean it seems like it
they're running all over the place
uh yeah this is deja vu all over again
it happens every day it continues to
happen the biden administration is not
doing what they need to do to stop this
as a matter of fact they're inviting it
and i've talked to border patrol many
times they are frustrated because they
get diverted by
having to deal with logistics and
handling these families you know we try
to help with texas dps we try to help
with the national guard but there's
still not enough to stop the type of
invitation that the biden administration
is allowing to happen how outmanned are
you
it's significant and honestly i feel i
feel bad for these border agents who are
risking their lives who are trying to do
their jobs they're not encouraged to do
their jobs they're not encouraged to to
protect the border they're not allowed
to have the resources that they need
they're not they're not putting up the
wall which border patrol would love to
have for their own safety let alone the
safety of those who are on the border so
it's incredibly frustrating when i talk
to these people who are just trying to
do their jobs when they're not given the
resources that they need and they're
again putting their lives at risk to
help us well the apprehensions are
seemingly at near record levels of many
years almost 2 million
in the last fiscal year um how do we
stop this you just mentioned the wall in
your state texas they've just allocated
what 250 million dollars to build your
own wall
well it's clear to me that the
administration does not want to stop
this they have
changed all the policies that stopped us
the trump administration had implemented
the remaining mexico program they had
they'd start deporting
criminals that they had that we had in
our jails the biden administration
stopped all of that we've had to sue
them we've sued them seven times we're
trying to get that implemented because
we've won they're supposed to be
implementing the stay in mexico program
so that these people don't come in claim
asylum like they're doing and then
disappear for years and then we never
find them and so we're doing our best
the biden administration is fighting us
every inch of the way trying to get as
many people in here illegally whether
they're criminals whether they're
transporting drugs it's all good with
them
do you think really that's fair to say
it's good for the body administration to
like
get drug dealers in that they're
encouraging it's fine if drug dealers
come in and criminals come in
absolutely they know exactly what's
happening they know that when our border
agents are busy taking care of hundreds
of thousands of people every month they
know that these cartels are gaining
strength they they charge for almost
everybody that crosses the borders not
getting across without paying the
cartels i think an average about eight
thousand at least that's what i've heard
from border patrol and from the people
that i've interviewed that have crossed
the border it's it's significant money
for the cartels the biden administration
knows this they're aiding abetting the
cartels and not only the transportation
of drugs but also the transportation of
human beings the administration is
expelling uh large numbers of people but
what do you want to see them do i mean
the vice president is the border czar uh
what should the administration do
i would encourage them to follow federal
law to to do what they are supposed to
do under federal law these laws have
been passed by congress signed by other
presidents and the biden administration
on day one said we're not enforcing
these laws and so if they would merely
just do what the trump administration
did which was enforce federal law put
the remaining mexico program back in
place deport criminals and start
building this wall we could have an
immigration policy that works and then
if we want to address adding more a
greater number of people to come here
legally i have no problem with that as
long as we're enforcing our laws and
this is done lawfully you know folks are
watching us right now you know they're
in maine they're up in oklahoma and
illinois out of north dakota and they're
saying well this doesn't really affect
me but you have said quote the harm is
the massive increase in crime
what are you seeing you you get it first
in texas what are you seeing and how
does that affect the rest of us well
it's certainly they're not going to be
affected like the people along the
border whose property is being damaged
who are scared to go out at night or
sometimes even in the day because they
don't know who's crossing their property
illegally they don't know if it's cartel
members or drug runners the runners that
you all just showed on on television are
probably not the people they want
crossing their property they have no
choice but what i'm saying is this this
is going to affect the entire nation
because as these people are moved around
secretly overnight on planes and buses
they have coveted some of them have
covered some of them are drug runners um
they are potentially criminals they
could be terrorists we don't know we
just know that they're being moved all
over the country and we also know we
aren't able to keep track of them
it is pretty astounding especially when
we just saw
four of those runners live with apparent
no consequence texas attorney general
ken paxton uh mr attorney general thank
you for joining us thank you good to see
you have a great day good to see you